In the next decade, millions of baby boomers will hit retirement age,...
...but they're too busy to talk about it...
...because retirement is just not on their radar screens.
People nearing retirement feel vague, emotional discomfort,...
...but tend not to plan anything other than travel,...
...fix-it chores, or moving to another locale...
...that's called the "first phase" of retirement.
It lasts about six months, and then the newly retired get antsy.
The second phase is an active phase of about 20 years.
That's when new retirees need to plan,...
...to understand who they are, or what they want to do-...
...this is a chance for a second career.
But what kind of career? Many don't want to be apartment superintendents,...
...but want work that uses skills developed over a lifetime.
Finding a fulfilling second career often depends on the retiree.
One-third of people who retire say they want to work part-time.
It's key to identify what your skills, abilities, values and interests are.
Once you can get a clear fix on what you want,...
...you will be able to find a venue to work in.
So don't fear retirement.
The whole concept of retirement does not fit the lexicon of those who chase their dreams...
...and do what they love.
Creative and powerful people all admit they would work without pay,...
...saying if you chase ideas, the money will come.
But if you chase money, the ideas get lost.